beaucoup plus léger à présent avec la
première journée des arts en maternelle
c'était cette semaine illustration à
l'école de la Blotterie à Joué-lès-Tours
reportage signé le
verre avec le vert le rouge avec le
rouge et le jaune avec le jaune
pas évident quand on est en maternelle
l'apprentissage se fait donc tout en
douceur avec des objets rapportés de la
maison et qui vont servir à dessiner une
fleur multicolore ou bien encore avec
des vêtements pour former des bulles de
couleurs pour la première année les
écoles maternelles du département ont
été invités à participer à une journée
des arts pour valoriser les pratiques
culturelles sous toutes leurs formes on
a associé un grand grand nombre
d'oeuvres et de propositions autour de
cette idée de la couleur parce que ce
qu'il faut dire en premier c'est que
cette journée elle s'appelle mon école
en couleur c'était un petit peu cette
idée d'envahir de de faire pénétrer la
couleur dans tout non seulement dans
tous les lieux les espaces de l'école
mais dans tous les moments voilà alors
quand certains l'installer leur
imaginaire d'autres s'appliquent à faire
des tampons pour décorer les arbres mais
qu'y a-t-il de plus amusant que de se
plonger les pieds dans la peinture
et c'est froid c'est est-ce que c'est
encore froid ou la peinture
ils sont de quelle couleur tes pieds
montre-moi
et même quand on est maîtresse il faut
bien jouer le jeu et montrer l'exemple
je me suis un petit peu impliquée dans
la peinture au pied parce que je sais
par expérience que que c'est une
expérience pas évidente forcément je
vais mettre ses pieds dans la peinture
c'est mais justement c'est une sensation
ça c'est important et voilà puis aussi
le plaisir un petit peu de faire avec
eux à la fin de la journée il faut tout
ramener à la maison et peut-être relaver
les mains les pieds et les jeans mais
qu'importe car quand on est artiste dans
l'âme tout est permis